i'll be okay
just to talk you through it
he starts doing his technique and he and
he moves me
and and
we'll get this on off on off on our
bearing
he can't get as an osmosis or the
equilibrium because he's so busy saying
what he seems to be going i said am i
doing it he's going with me i must have
it correct but i don't know if i've got
it correct so do you know what i mean by
saying that as well
so there's no
equilibrium
because even when he's moving you
nobody knows where the balance is
because what each person is thinking oh
he's helped me
nobody stops and thinks
has he got me why are we just going
along together is this osmosis become
something that has just happened
and we just then
got down there
this is what i see is equilibrium
i turned
watch this part
so yeah i've moved him off his center
now
so this what we've been talking about
i don't really rate that teacher but
but what he's doing is he's working on
the inner mind
and some
equilibrium
so now
we've made this
he's not thinking on off or not he's
just thinking
since he's pulling me around and running
around and i don't know about it
so it means we're we've joined because
he doesn't have a gap to think for
himself or to think about
he doesn't have a yes no scenario going
on he doesn't have
i've got him
yes
cutting down really i was doing that
with danny
this time
i'm doing that with danny
he just doesn't know it
i'm pushing him away mentally all the
time
okay so that was the mental that was the
going on to the mental side